si usted lo mencionaba los pasos
entonces a seguir es que el comité este
nuevo comité se reúna el próximo martes
19 de octubre genere este reporte este
reporte después pasaría a votación en
plenaria de la cámara de representantes
plenaria el pleno de la cámara de
representantes que es controlado por la
mayoría demócrata después entonces el
nancy pelosi la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes tendría que certificar
esta votación y una vez certificada a
nancy pelosi le enviaría entonces este
reporte ya certificado al fiscal general
del distrito de columbia ya sería
entonces el fiscal quien toma la
decisión si judicial iza o no a steven
banon esto según varios expertos legales
puede tardar años teniendo en cuenta
además que se pueden venir contra
demandas y además teniendo en cuenta el
historial de donald trump el ex
presidente pues él siempre tiende a
contrademandar cuando se ve en presiones
legales así que esto podría tomar años y
lo que analistas políticos están
diciendo es que de avanzar este proceso
pues steven banon y el tropismo y del
expresidente de donald trump pues se
verían de alguna manera en una posición
como de mártires y esto no tendría un
efecto muy positivo en el partido
demócrata de cara a elecciones
legislativas el próximo año y
presidenciales en el 2024 ahora a
cristóbal contándonos cuál habría sido
concretamente el rol de banon en el
ataque al capitolio
y en esta ocasión el comité de este
comité selecto que investiga lo que pasó
el 6 de enero pues éxitos a banon por la
conversación que tuvo con el ex
presidente
donald trump el 30 de diciembre en esta
conversación banon ya habría dicho el ex
presidente de donald trump que enfocará
todos sus esfuerzos en el 6 de enero una
fecha clave acá en washington este año
porque precisamente el 6 de enero era
cuando se iba a llevar esta megamarcha
de trompistas en la capital marcha que
terminaba en el capitolio y precisamente
ese día durante esa marcha se llevaba
también a cabo la ceremonia de
certificación de los votos para
certificar al nuevo presidente joe biden
en la casa blanca y lo que también dice
el comité es que citaba habana porque el
5 de enero un día antes precisamente del
6 de enero ya se había reunido en el
hotel willard para hablar con
congresistas para que precisamente no
reconocieran los resultados de las
elecciones
y por último qué pasará con los otros
tres funcionarios de la administración
de donald trump que fueron citados a
rendir indagatoria
lo que está diciendo el comité y lo dijo
además en un comunicado es que estas
personas están empezando a colaborar
empezando a entregar información a tener
conversaciones del comité lo dijo que
tan profundas o qué tan extensas fueron
estas informaciones que empezaron a
compartir pateó mark meadows que fue el
jefe de gabinete del ex presidente
donald trump y entonces el comité dijo
que precisamente por esta colaboración
que están teniendo ya que están
empezando a hacer estas personas pues va
a postergar entonces las audiencias que
tenían esta semana hoy y mañana estas
personas acá en la cama de
representantes